good morning John good morning John it's
morning John
good morning John pax was amazing got a
bunch of signed MC Frontalot posters
obviously really overwhelming really fun
to go to a conference that I'm not
running not to hang out with a bunch of
cool people and now I'm just doing the
thing where I talk about the conference
for a second so that I could show a
bunch of footage that it took at the
conference that I wouldn't be able to
show otherwise it Z has footage footage
yes good that's yeah excellent uh-huh
that was fun okay done with that we have
to move on they're serious pressing
issues here as you can see by the title
of the video there is a Jew's lurking
just behind Google's front door the top
questions asked to Google that begin
with can you really number one can you
really sell your soul I don't know why I
find this so disappointing are people
trying to sell their soul do they think
that they've already sold their soul or
someone purchased their soul without
them knowing are we in that much debt
but now as far as I know there's no way
to transfer the ownership of a soul from
one person to another for a variety of
reasons one of those reasons being if it
were possible you'd see it on Craigslist
all the time it'd have its own category
- can you really tip a cow no actually
cows are really big really strong
surprisingly smart animals that sleep
lying down I'm sure it would be possible
to tip a cow if you had enough people
and in the right situation but you can't
just run up to one and shove it over
their massive animals and I would really
suggest against bothering one because
every adult cow in the world outweighs
every adult human in the world by at
least a thousand pounds it actually may
be miniature cows out there I don't know
are they're miniature council let me
look it up yeah of course they're
miniature cows what was I thinking
can you really curve a bullet no only
Angelina Jolie can do that the genetic
thing what a terrible movie I actually
saw it in theaters can you really make
money blogging yes Ashley did it for
several years I paid all of my bills
with blogging it was really hard and now
the scene is much more crowded and
competitive than it ever was then but if
you're serious about it go to coffee
blogger.com because that guy helped me a
lot Carson's creature can you really fry
an egg on the sidewalk yes in many
places you can really fry an egg on the
sidewalk when it's hot in the summer
time does not however take that much
heat to cook an egg but check out this
horrible video of soldiers whose boots
are Mel
thing to the pavement in Iraq high-five
to those guys come back soon
can you really die of a broken heart
actually the sad fact that a manner of
speaking is yes you can
grief is very stressful and it turns out
the people who have recently lost loved
ones are much more likely to die in the
24 hours following the loss of a loved
one you are 21 times more likely to have
a heart attack
so that is yes indeed very literally a
broken heart can you really get rid of
cellulite you can maintain a healthy
body weight and you can also get
expensive plastic surgery but the creams
aren't gonna do you any good but really
come on I think you're gorgeous can you
really get a free iPad yes you can steal
one but you are not going to get a free
iPad by taking an online survey because
duh can you really light a fart yes of
course you can farts are composed of
many different things including methane
and hydrogen which are both flammable
gases but I have to suggest that you do
not try this because it turns out that
it's fairly dangerous to hold an
ignition source up to your flammable
pants and then provide a great deal of
fuel for that ignition source to spread
across the surface of your pants I can't
imagine how that could go wrong can you
really start a fire with an orange is
another viral video where some guy
filled an orange up with lighter fluid
and was like look oranges are flammable
they're not they're mostly made of water
and water is inflammable fructose and
cellulose are flammable and that's it
but you'd have to dehydrate it first and
then you could light it on fire and
that's where we'll end it everybody
don't try to sell your soul do purchase
iPads don't try to get them for free
stop trying to light everything on fire
don't worry about your cellulite
everybody's got it and send all your
warm good thoughts to all the broken
hearts out there John I'll see you on
Tuesday